well don't stop shoot I guess we've got
to stop I will I will soon go into
withdrawal symptoms so last about six
weeks but on the other hand we all are
beginning to develop a sort of tired and
desperate look and perhaps it's good
thing to get the semester behind us and
go into solstice hibernation anyway
there's a lot to do today I want to wrap
up a couple of things talk about what's
next and maybe get into some big issues
perhaps a little Genesis demo that sort
of thing so here's what we're going to
do first last time I talked about this
whole idea of structure discovery and
really the whole reason I cracked and
started talking about Bayesian methods
is because of the potential utility of
taking that idea one step further and
finding structure in situations where
you might not otherwise find it it's
still an open question about whether
that's the best way to think about it
but here it goes
imagine you've got a couple of stories
and these circles represent the events
in the story I know what you like to get
out of these stories is some kind of
finite state graph that describes the
collection of stories so you might
discover for example that these two
events are quite similar and these two
events are quite similar so you might
use that as a basis for speculating and
maybe a more compact way of representing
the stuff in the story would look like
this where this one let's see this one
goes with this one this one goes with
this one and there's a possibility of
another state in between so that's the
notion of Bayesian story merging and now
I'd like to show you a little bit more
convincing demonstration of that here's
how it goes
so there are the two stories this is
just a classroom demonstration no big
deal
but you can see there's a sort of
parallel structure in there so this is
the work of a graduate student mark
Fillion who process those stories to
produce those kinds of events and those
kinds of events that get assembled into
two story graphs and the question is is
this the most probable way of explaining
that corpus of stories and of course the
answer is no if you merge some things
like chase and stalk then you get a
simpler graph one that is more probable
in the same sense that we discussed last
time then you can marry merge run and
flee cuz they're similar kinds of events
and finally you've got think and decide
boom there is your story graph and this
is the same idea taken several levels
higher to produce the capacity to
discover in these two stories the
concept of revenge as promised at the
beginning of our last discussion so
sometimes the Bayesian stuff is the
right thing to do especially if you
don't know anything but sometimes you do
not know stuff and when you do know
stuff it's possible you can do something
very much more efficient this sort of
thing takes clouds of computers to
process but we learn a lot of stuff in a
course of our development that we don't
use a cloud of computers to figure out
we learn how to associate the gestures
of our mouth with the sounds that we
make for example so I want to spend a
minute or two talking about
some work that someday will be the
subject of a couple of lectures I think
but it's the question of how to use
multiple modalities and correspondences
between them to sort out
both of the contributing modalities that
that sounds complicated let me show you
an example this is the example a zebra
finch and it's um it's a showing you a
the result of a program written by
Michael Cohen now professor at the
University of Wisconsin so the zebra
finch learns the male zebra finch learns
to sing a nice mating call mating song
from its daddy and this is what one such
zebra finch sounds like nice do you
think and here is what was learned by a
program that uses no probabilistic stuff
at all but rather the notion of cross
modal coupling you tell the difference
it's not known that this particular song
turns on the female zebra finch but to
the untrained human ear they sure sound
a whole lot of light so how does that
work here's how that works well I'm not
going to show you how that works what
I'm going to show you is how the
classroom example works the the the
first chapter example i'm fillin PhD
thesis here's what happens when we talk
we produce a Fourier transform that
moves along with our speech and if we
say a vowel like ah you get a fairly
constant Fourier spectrum and you can
say well where are the peaks in that
Fourier spectrum and how do they
correspond to the appearance of my mouth
when I say the vowel so here's how that
how here's how that works
so here's the Fourier spectrum of a
particular vowel and when you smooth
that those Peaks are called formants and
so we're just going to keep track of the
first and second formant but when I say
those things
I also conform an ellipse around my
mouth when I say them and when I form an
ellipse around my mouth when I say them
that gives me the second the second
modality so the question is is there a
way of associating the gestures that
produce the sound with the sound itself
well there's the human data conveniently
provided by a variety of sources
including Michael Cohen's wife who
produce the lip contour data on the
right so that's all marked up and color
coded according to the particular sound
to the particular vowels in English I
guess there are ten of them so we humans
all learn that but guess what we don't
learn it from this because we know get
to work with any marked up data we
learned from that somehow we're exposed
to the nature to the natural world and
we dig the vowel sounds out it's a
fantastic how we do that but we do have
cross modal coupling data and maybe
that's got something to do with it so
here is a particular cluster of sounds
and what I want to know is can I merge
any of these two clusters to form a
bigger cluster with a corresponding
meaning so what I can do is I can say
well I can watch these site I know about
I know what the lip lip form is when a
particular sound is made so I have these
correspondences so maybe there are four
of those like so and maybe the same guy
projects a couple of times into that and
the question is can this guy be combined
with any of these guys and the answer is
yes if they're close together on one
side maybe that suggests you got to
cluster them on the other side but
there's a question about what close
means
so let's suppose that we also look at
how these guys these other two guys
project and suppose this guy projects
twice up here and once over here and
this guy down here just projects like
crazy into that guy which are closer
these two or these two well my diagram
is getting a little closer but if you
paid attention when I was drawing it you
would see that this guy projects in
proportion to that guy so if we look at
the if we take each of these projections
as the components of a vector then those
two vectors are in the same direction
and a cosine between them is zero so
these are two either the two that are
closest together from that from the
perspective of that kind of metric and
those guys are the ones who get combined
try to see a demonstration yeah okay
here's demonstration based on Cohen's
work
so here we have two sides you could
think of one side is being vowel sounds
and other side is being lip contours or
something but you don't see anything in
the diagram so far about how these
things ought to be sorted out into
groups so if I just take one step what
it discovers that those two guys have
the same projection pattern as each
other so if I take another step I do the
same thing on the other side and now in
the third step the two areas that were
formerly combined now form a super area
and they're seen to project in the same
way as the blue area so using this kind
of projection idea
I can gradually build up an
understanding of how those regions go
together and I discover in this
contrived example that there's a
vertical arrangement on the right side
that corresponds to a horizontal
arrangement on the left side when you
say to me I like to see something a
little bit more like the lip contour
data I'm just stepping through here
until I get something I kind of like oh
that sounds good that seems good so
there's a correspondence here this is
all this is all made up data Gaussian
you know gaussians of various shapes and
orientations let's see what happens when
I run the clustering algorithm on that
something definite was learned in every
step we find the correspondence between
the pink region on the right and the
pink region on the left in some cases
where the regions are rather blurred
together the other side is the one that
helps the system figure out how things
are organized so I'd say this is an
example of something I think is very
important number one it's possible to
discover regularity without being
obsessively concerned with Bayesian
probability and also that there's a that
there's very likely a whole lot of this
going on in human intelligence and we
when we when we emerge and begin to
examine and explore the world around us
and we're presented with a lot of
unlabeled data that we've got to make
sense of and I believe that this kind of
cross modal coupling idea is very much
likely very likely to be bound up in our
understanding of that world that's
presented to us it's fast its direct it
doesn't take thousands of data points it
just happens and it happens effortlessly
and this isn't built-in this isn't
determined to be built-in you can come
back to MIT in 15 years put me in jail
so I think this is really the way it
works so there it is there's a couple of
things to have wrapped up and now next
thing I want to do and the for the rest
of our last time together in this format
is talk to you about a variety of things
and I'll depart from my usual practice
and move to some slides so Dave do we
have the center screen please
so first a brief review of where we
where we've been and where we've come I
think on the in the very first class I
talked about what artificial
intelligence was and I talked about how
you could view it from either an
engineering perspective or a scientific
perspective I'm on the scientific
perspective side and I think I have
nothing against applications but I think
we'll have be able to make much more
sophisticated and and and wonderful
applications if we have not only the
engineering perspective about building
stuff but also the scientific
perspective about understanding the
stuff to begin with so the both
perspectives are important and in this
case you can say they all involve
representations methods and
architectures Dave I changed my mind
could you also give me the side screen
so I can see it too so that's that
what's next the business perspective
which we talked about on Thanksgiving
the important idea being that the
knee-jerk expectation that the
commercial value of something is in
replacing people is something that is
not sensible in the first instance and
demonstrate it to be unlikely and untrue
in the second instance the thing that
turns people on from the point of view
of applications is not replacing people
but making new revenue making new
capability and that it once licenses you
to not have something done exclusively
by a computer that's something that can
be done in partnership with a person so
all of the important applications of
artificial intelligence involve people
and computers working in tandem with
each doing what they do best
not with replacing people so that's that
here's what AI does that makes AI
different from the rest of the fields
that attempt to contribute to an
understanding of intelligence we have
the benefit of having a language for
procedures we have all the metaphors
that we that we are the custodians of
and consequent
of knowing about programming we have the
metaphor of garbage collection we can
talk about all sorts of things with
programming metaphors that are
unavailable to people in other fields
that are interested in psychology we
have a way to make models because we can
write programs and when we write
programs there's no question of sweeping
things under the rug we have to work out
the details and once we've done all that
then we have opportunities to experiment
that are beyond the ability to
experiment in most other fields Oh
magnificent experiments are done these
days in developmental psychology and all
the rest of all the other branches of
psychology including MRI studies that
probe into your brain and see how it's
consuming sugar but it's very difficult
to ablate or take away some piece of
your knowledge and see how you work
without it I can take the line-drawing
program that we talked about and say how
will it do if it doesn't know anything
about fork junctions and we can
determine an answer but I can't reach
into Sebastian's head here with this
surgical procedure and take out his
knowledge of fork junctions it just
can't be done and finally another reason
why we're different is because we can
put upper bounds on how much knowledge
is needed in order to perform a certain
kind of task these days with bulldozers
are computing the question is that most
often ask is how can you get billions of
things off the web and use them we I
especially sometimes ask the opposite
question which is how much help how
little knowledge can you have and still
understand the story that's what's
interesting to me
so there's a methodological slide that
talks to the question of how you do
artificial intelligence particular and I
suppose science in general engineering
in general there's a great tendency to
in this field to fall in love with
particular methods and we've had people
who've devoted entire careers to neural
nets genetic algorithms Bayesian
probability and that's mechanism Envy
and a better way in my judgment is to
say what is the problem scientific
method what's the problem and then bring
the right machinery to bear on the
problem rather than looking for things
to do with a particular kind of
machinery so this is the methodology the
first articulated in a forceful way by
David Marr you want to start with the
competence you're trying to understand
then bring a representation to bear on
it a representation that exposes the
constraints and regularities because
without those you can't make models and
without those models you can't
understand it explain it predicted or
control it so it seems to make sense
from a kind of MIT model centered point
of view and only when you've got all
that straight do you start working on
your methods and implement an experiment
and then go around that around that loop
so that's all I want to say by way of
review I suppose I want to take a minute
or two and just remind you about what's
on the final there's nothing to remind
because you all know what's on the final
already we'll have four sections
corresponding the four exams then we'll
have a fifth and final question that
will be everything else all that stuff
you slept through well we featured there
as well as the a little problem on the
Bayesian inference we didn't we
rearranged the subject mostly so I could
write the demonstrations so as some of
the Bayesian stuff didn't come before
the fourth quiz therefore the Bayesian
stuff that you see on those previous
quizzes is likely to be harder than the
that will ask on the final because you
haven't had as much experience with it
as people did last year I've got a few
icons on there to remind me to tell you
a few things as always open everything
except for computers you can wear a
costume you can do anything you like as
long as it doesn't disturb your neighbor
within reason well I guess if it doesn't
disturb your neighbor it is within
reason so maybe that's all I need to say
we will I forgot I'm not sure where
we're going to be but it's certainly the
case that historically there are no
visible clocks so we soon went out of
all of our cell phones wristwatches and
other timepieces as we hand them out so
it pays to remember to bring some kind
of timepiece because we won't be able to
convey the time very well and finally I
see a little calculator there I don't
recall any examine where you actually
needed a calculator but it's sort of a
security blanket to have one people
sometimes see a problem.i god what am I
going to do I left my calculator at home
so as to avoid that anxiety you might
want to bring one even though you won't
eat it so that's the final I'm sure they
no questions are there it's obvious
everybody will do well two shots you
know that whole thing now what I doing
what to do next suppose this subject is
turn you on there are a variety of
things that you should they be thinking
about doing next semester and I wanted
to review just a few of those one of
them is Marvin Minsky's the subject
society of mine it's very different from
this class there are no prepared
lectures the Marvin doesn't rehearse he
doesn't think about what he's going to
say in advance and saying it's it's like
this except it's just a conversation
with Marvin so many people find
themselves bored stiff 4-4-2 lecturers
out of three but then in the third
lecture Marvin will say something that
you'll think about for a year or for the
rest of your life
that's what
to me I'm bored stiff two out of three
times than the third lecture he says
something and I think about it for at
least a year and maybe permanently so
it's an opportunity to see whether my
teas true geniuses think out loud so
it's an experience that you don't want
to miss because it's what you come here
for is this either
the geniuses think out loud
speaking of geniuses then there's a
there's Bob Berwick and he heroically is
doing two subjects in the spring both of
which I'd take if I could one is his
subject on language understand
understanding and the reason I take that
is because I believe that language is at
the center of any explanation of our
intelligence so that's the subject I
would be I suppose most inclined to take
the far if I were you well maybe
Minsky's it's hard to say and
incidentally very heroically Bob is also
teaching a course on how evolution works
how it really works
insofar as we know how it really works
as well so both of those will be offered
in the spring I don't know how he does
it don't know how he does too all at the
same time of course there are lots of
places where you can go to school and
the faculty will be teaching five
courses at the same time I just think
they're crazy or something I don't know
how that works Gerry Sussman will be
teaching his large-scale symbolic system
subject that's sometimes oh I forgot
what he wasn't able to call it something
that wasn't politically correct about
programming for people who really really
liked a program it's a splendid course
on how to build really big systems and
we use the ideas in that subject in our
research system because it's the only
way understanding how that works is the
only way that you can build systems that
are too big to be built I may say a word
about that a little later so those are
the those are my favorite 3/4 picks but
there's lots of other stuff too many
things to cover the Media Lab brain and
cognitive psychology there's tons of
stuff out there
and I would only mention that courses
that have those three names on them are
bound to be good these are colleagues
that I think have a important
perspective not necessarily one I agree
with but an important perspective that
you should understand Richards 10 Melvin
Sinha and now we come to my supreme
force the human intelligence Enterprise
at 6 xxx not because there's anything
pornographic about it but because for a
long time I couldn't remember its number
so I developed a habit of referring to
it at 6 xxx and it seems to have stuck
here's what that's about
yeah that might be interesting it's a
it's taught like a humanities course
though no lectures I just talked and all
of the TAS are veterans of that class if
you want to know if you should do it you
can
there's several you have several
resources you got you could talk to them
or I don't know you could look at the
sorts of things we talked about here are
some things we talked about by way of
packaging
yeah I can hear a little tittering there
because people have discovered the last
element some people take a whole subject
because they want to be present for that
unit but we talk about all those kinds
of things and we look to see what the
common elements are and all those kinds
of packaging problems of the sort that
you will face over and over again when
you become an adult no matter what you
do if you're become a business person an
entrepreneur a military officer a
scientist or an engineer that packaging
stuff will often make the difference
between whether you succeed or don't and
then that's the second way you can
figure out whether you want to take the
subject the content the TAS and then of
course you can always appeal to the
underground guide and that's why it's
all it's very rare for someone to take
6xx who hasn't been at this final
lecture because they read the
underground guide here is an element
that appeared the underground guide a
few years back
there are no exams but there is a
tradition of hacking the underground
guide so this is another example of
something that appeared so it all came
about because early in the teaching of
six xxx I was whining to the students
about the fact that MIT MIT for a long
time since I was a freshman and I've
still have yet to have any person I
report to say anything about my teaching
good bad indifferent what you know
nothing not a word so the students
decided that it would be interesting to
see if they could say something
sufficiently outrageous to force a
conversation between the department
chairman and me and so far they've been
totally unsuccessful and I've tried
everything
Winston shows up late if he shows up at
all a good instructor but constantly
sipping from a brown paper bag
all kinds of stuff but there it is it's
a lot of fun it's a little over
subscribe so we have to have a lottery
and there's about 50% chance and so on
and so forth but many of you will find
it finally a good thing to do oh yeah I
know I also want to remind myself that
there is a IP event it's become kind of
MIT tradition it's the how to speak
lecture that I give this year will be on
January 28th in six 126 120 holds about
120 people and about 250 show up so if
you want to go to that lecture you
should show up 15 minutes early that's a
little secret just between me and 603
for students it's about it's about
packaging - it's a one lecture version
of 6 xxx but it's very nonlinear because
one thing that you pick up from that
one-hour may make the difference between
you getting the job and some other slug
getting the job so it's one of those
sorts of things that can make a big
difference in a short period of time you
may sleep through 50 minutes of the 55
minutes in that lecture and stay away
for that one magical five minutes when
you learn something about when to tell a
joke or how to open a lecture or how to
conclude one or a job talk or a sales
presentation or anything and that will
make it worthwhile for you and then of
course there's the possibility of Europe
anybody who's doing Europe with me is
likely to be interested in what I've
recently come to call the strong story
hypothesis something we've talked about
from time to time you know that's what
that's what makes us humans and that's
not what they are they're regular tans
or chimpanzees even though the DNA that
we share is it goes up and down at one
point it was 96% then I went to
ninety-eight now I think it's back down
to 97 but whatever we are it's not
because of a huge massive difference in
DNA between us and our cousins so in my
group we build the Genesis system
modestly called and that's what it looks
like and it has in it all the sorts of
things that we've talked about from time
to time in six oh three four and it's
about to move into areas that are
especially interesting like can you
detect the onset of a possible disaster
before it happens and intervene can you
retrieve precedents based on
higher-level concepts things of that
sort would you would you like to see a
demonstration
okay so you've seen a little bit of this
before in fact I'm not not even sure
what exactly I've already shown you but
let me just get over there to see what
that it goes on here what I'm going to
do right now is I'm just going to read
read about Macbeth a short Crecy
of the plot not the whole thing of
course just just a few sentences about
the plot right now what it's doing is
its absorbing the English and
translating into a sort of internal
language sort of in a universal internal
language it's all about trajectories and
transitions and social relationships and
all that so it's being read there by two
two different persona each of those
personas has a different educational
background you might say it might
represent they might represent different
cultures so eventually they build up
graphs like that and everything in white
is stuff that's explicit in the story
and everything it's in in Bray is stuff
that's been inferred by the system so
there are several layers of
understanding one is what's there
explicitly and another thing is there is
stuff that's readily inferred and
because these persona have different
educational backgrounds you might say
they see the killing
of Macbeth at the end of the play in a
different light from one another one
sees it as an act of insane violence and
the other sees it is a consequence of a
revenge so once you've got that
capability you can do all sorts of
things for example you can ask questions
so let me arrange to ask by the way this
is a live demonstration I've thrilled to
pieces that it actually works so far
let's see why did Matt oops Matt Guf
kill Duncan you all know why right done
10 yeah you're right he didn't actually
do that on a common sense level neither
drives Jeff nor mr. Hyde have an opinion
on a reflective level neither dr jekyll
nor mr. hyde have an opinion that's
because it didn't happen so we called
these two persona doclet dr. Jekyll and
mr. Hyde and you'd complain right away
about the spelling of Jekyll aren't you
well that's because with this spelling
it's the speech generator makes us sound
a little bit more like where we say
Jekyll but what really happened is the
Macduff killed Macbeth on a common-sense
level it looks like dr. general thinks
Macduff kills Macbeth because Macduff
isn't sane it looks like mr. Hyde thinks
Macduff kills Macbeth because matt bevin
Gers Macduff on a reflective level it
looks like dr. general thinks Macduff
kills Macbeth is part of act of insane
violence it looks like mr. Hyde thinks
Macduff kills Macbeth is part of X of
mistake birra victory and revenge yeah
cool I'll bet you get an A if you just
said that in eighth grade
but once you've got this this ability to
understand the story from multiple
points of view you begin to think of all
kinds of wonderful things you can do for
example you can have dr. Jekyll
negotiate with mr. Hyde because dr.
Jekyll will be able to understand mr.
Hyde's point of view and demonstrate mr.
Hyde that he thinks that point of view
is legitimate or dr. Jekyll can teach
mr. Hyde the subject matter of a new
domain or dr. Jekyll can watch what's
happening in mr. Hyde's mind and avert
disaster before it happens so let me
just show you another situation here I
want to turn on the onset detector and
read another little snippet this one is
about what should I do we'll do the
Russia Estonia cyber war it's reading
background knowledge right now but
pretty soon in the upper left hand
corner as it begins to read this story
you'll see it spotting the onset of
potential revenge operations or
potential Pyrrhic victories and show
that they they're their foundations
begin to emerge in giving the system an
opportunity to to intervene so there you
can see all of the things that it thinks
might happen not all of them do happen
but some of them do and you'll note
incidentally that in this is another
case of dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde having
different cultural perspective
perspectives one's an ally of Russia
one's an ally of Estonia one sees it as
unwarranted revenge and the other sees
it as teaching a lesson so I don't know
what else we got here I have a president
recall a long time ago we talked about
retreat doing information retrieval
based on vectors of keyword counts
that's cool but not this cool this is
doing on vectors of concepts that appear
in the stories such as revenge even
though the word revenge doesn't appear
anywhere so because we're able
to understand the story on multiple
levels we can use those higher levels
that don't involve the words in the
story at all to drive the retrieval
process so all that is a consequence of
a variety of things one of which is the
specialists the the translate the
English into an internal language and
it's also incidentally I mentioned a
little before and it's also a
consequence of our use of Gerry
Sussman's propagator architecture so a
student comes into our group and we says
we wants to do something okay
here's how the system is organized it's
like a bunch of boxes that are wired
together so you get a box and we'll tell
you what the inputs are going to look
like and we'll tell you what we want on
the outputs if you don't like the inputs
just ignore them and if we don't like
your outputs we'll just ignore that so
nobody can screw up anything because
they have a very circumscribed piece of
the system to work with so I can say for
example the president wanted Iraq to
move toward democracy and bingo all US
starts a propagation through that
network
all this would be unconvincing in my
view if warned eventually connected to
perception because if it's not
eventually connected with perception
it's yet another system that
demonstrates how smart it can seem to be
without actually knowing anything so
another half of what we do is a early
stage attempt to connect the language
stuff with things that are going on in
the world so we say imagine a jumping
action and there is a jumping action
it's part of a test suite developed by
the Defense Research Projects Agency to
drive what they call the mind's eye
program which was developed largely as a
consequence of work done here at MIT
focused on the idea that if we're going
to understand the nature of intelligence
we have to understand how language is
coupled into our perceptual systems at
how those perceptual systems can answer
questions posed to them by the language
system so that's a little demo with a
Genesis system here are the issues that
we're trying to explore nothing too
serious just the nature of what is
extraordinarily fundamental to any
explanation of human thinking now you
might all this might turn you on you
would say to me well you're sick and
tired of MIT you'd like to go somewhere
else for graduate school so now that
demonstrated what we do here one of the
things many things we do here I'll talk
a little bit about other places you can
go this is a sort of MIT centric view of
the world it's um
it represents all of the places you
could go when I was a kid but while I've
got this particular diagram on here I
just sort of testimony MIT arrogance I
remember a story often told by my
colleague Peter salivic he says that
when he came to a job interview from
Caltech MIT he was sitting here for
three days nobody spoke to him so
eventually said I got to do something he
walked up to a graduate student and said
hi my name is Peter Salvage I'm from
Caltech
and the graduate students said Caltech
sucks and walked away anyway we've
populated all these places now that you
see here and more this is just a list I
scratched up this morning I'm sure I've
forgotten many that are that have equal
right to be on this list but in the end
which one you go to depends on who you
want to apprentice yourself to because
the Graduate School is an apprenticeship
and that means if you go to a place with
just one person it's okay if that's the
person you want to apprentice yourself
to each of these places has a different
focus because they have different people
so you need to find out if there's
somebody of these places doesn't matter
if it's a I or some other field
theoretical physics you got to find out
if there's somebody at that place you
you want to apprentice yourself to so
those site visits are really important
and I would like to also stress that
when you make your application to
graduate school it's very different from
it applying to an undergraduate school
because they don't care whether their
school is good for you at all they only
care about one thing whether you're good
for their school so don't get confused
and talk about how it's a wonderful fit
for you because what they're interested
is whether you're going to contribute to
their research program oh I should say
that you're applying artificial
intelligence that means you don't say
I'm interested in all aspects of
thinking you need to be focused there's
another reason why you don't say that
you're interested in all aspects of
thinking and that is the defect theory
of AI career selection it seems to be
the case strange though it may seem the
people and artificial intelligence too
often do specialize the research on the
things that they don't do very well
themselves so people who study language
with the exception of Bob Berg often
have trouble getting out a coherent
sentence and people who do hand-eye
coordination are the source of spilled
our coffee so don't say you want to
study all of thinking because most
extreme case of this though was if you
don't my I'll tell you a story about
screen case this I we had a visitor from
Japan and the al artificial intelligence
lab many years ago came for a year let's
call him let's call him Yoshiaki just to
pick a name Yoshiaki he spent a year at
the artificial intelligence lab and he
left his wife in japan and the reason
was she was pregnant
and at that time he could not get into
visa to the United States unless she had
a smallpox vaccination and because she
was pregnant she didn't want to get a
smallpox vaccination because there's a
small danger of all danger to the fetus
if you get a smallpox vaccination while
you're pregnant so she stayed back there
so Yoshiaki let us call him there was a
day before he was to get on the airplane
to go home I walked into his office and
his this was covered with pictures of
his wife by the way Yoshiaki I should
tell you is a computer vision guy
interested in object recognition so you
might suspect he has some problem so
he's looking at these pictures I thought
oh my god this is a tender moment he's
anticipating his return to Japan and
reunion with his wife so I muttered
something that effect he looked at me
like I was a king of the fools and he
said it's not a question of tenderness
I'm afraid I won't recognize her at the
Tokyo Airport so so I said Yoshiaki how
can this be you studied computer vision
you study object recognition this is
your wife how can you not how can you
think it wouldn't recognize her at the
Tokyo Airport and then he looks at me I
God is my witness he says they all look
alike
well now as we come close to the end one
of the big questions is useful of course
it's useful it's part of the toolkit now
of everybody who claims to be a computer
sciences what are the powerful ideas
these things well here are here's the
most powerful powerful idea is the idea
of powerful idea and here are a few of
my favorites nothing no surprises there
that's just Winston's picks but there's
one more I would like to add and that is
all great ideas are simple a lot of
times we NMIT confuse value with
complexity and many of the things that
were simplest in this subject are
actually the most powerful so be careful
about confusing simplicity with
triviality and thinking that something
can't be important unless it's
complicated and deeply mathematical it's
usually the intuition that's powerful
and the mathematics is the buttressing
element sometimes people argue that real
our intelligence is possible one of the
most common arguments is well what if we
had a room and you're in the room and
you're asked to translate some Chinese
documents you've got a bunch of books
and in the end you can do the
translation but you cannot be said to
understand Chinese this is the argument
of california-berkeley philosopher named
cyril so the trouble is is also true
well if the argument is you know the
books aren't intelligent they're just
ink on a page and the person is just a
computer just a processor it doesn't
actually have know anything so since it
can't be in either the person or the
books it can't be that just forgets that
there's a magic that comes about when a
running program when a process executes
in time over knowledge that it
continually contributes to so the
reduction are the reductionist arguments
are among the many that have been
ineffectually opposed to argue that
artificial intelligence is impossible
but that the bear is longer discussion
let me just bring up the biggest issue
in my mind which is it's not the
question of whether we humans are too
smart to me to have our intelligence
duplicated or excelled in a computer
it's a question whether we're smart
enough to pull it off I once had a pet
raccoon now it's illegal to have a pet
raccoon but this this one was an orphan
it's a mother had been hit by a car some
something a friend of my brought the
raccoon to me know he had kind of like
animals and I have to say I kept the
raccoon for a year and at that point she
was she wanted to go out and be on her
own so so I have this raccoon and this
record is smarter than any dog I've ever
had within a day she learned how to pry
the refrigerator door open so I spent
that whole year taping the refrigerator
door shut every time and then we played
jokes on each other she would she
wouldn't eat hot dogs and I wanted to
eat hot dogs desperately because they're
cheap and easy to serve all she would
eat with was cooked chicken wings
we need hotbox so one day I said well
I'm going to play a trick on her I took
a chicken bone I stuck it in the middle
of hot dog and put it in a garbage can
and she went for it
her genes took over and she went for it
and she was happy with had two hot dogs
ever after she wouldn't let me read she
would crawl up underneath the book and
interfere and make me she want to always
want to suck on my thumb which turned
blue eventually he'd be am amazed at how
how much a raccoon can suck that's just
an extremely powerful the best parts
were which he would go bike riding with
me I put on a heavy sweater because they
have a pretty good grip I put on a heavy
sweater and she'd kind of round herself
on my back and kind of look out over my
shoulder stop traffic for miles around
so she was really smart but you know the
interesting thing is that at no point
did I ever presume that that raccoon was
smart enough to build a machine that was
as smart as a raccoon so when we think
that we can it involves a certain
element of hubris that may not may or
may not be justified well there it is
just a couple more things to do one of
which is you should understand that
Kendra and Kenny when you on and Martin
and glib are doing a lot of stuff that's
outside the job description all of these
all of these quiz review deals that
they've arranged are not in the job
description I didn't ask him to do it
that's all just plain old
professionalism so they've been
wonderful to work with and I just like
to
offer them a round of applause and of
course Bob and Randy and Mark done
fabulous stuff as well and we of the
rest of the staff
the TAS Marc Valvo Randy
nothing else to do except wish you good
hunting on the final and a good long
winter solstice hibernation period after
that and that is the end of the story
and we hope you live happily ever after
you